hello everyone and welcome to another
very interesting and very exciting game
also from the tournament of peace held
in Zagreb Vasily when sugar versus Sir
Robert Del Cheech and I didn't think I'd
be showing any more videos
well more games from this event but I
forget forgot to mention in the previous
video that Chuck you won't event without
losing a single game so I decided to
show another video and also show the
final standings so without further ado
let's check it out
with the white pieces chalky opens with
d4 now we have Knight to f6 by cell to
c4 with a 6 sorry about that
Knight to c3 and Bishop to b4 the
nimzo-indian defense we have Knight to
f3 and B 6 by soldier Bishop to d2 with
Bishop to be 7th in theater in the light
square Bishop and now g3 hierarchy is
ready to do the same with castles and
Bishop to g2 and now these six is the
common well the the most played move
here but we have c5 by selfish it's a
it's quite a rare move although it has
been played before now we have D captors
and c5 and here Boris Gelfand had this
position with white against Vladimir
Kramnik in the 2005 amber tournament and
the Kramnik won that game he played
Bishop captures and c5 but here we have
B captures on c5 which extremely rare
and here we have just castles by chalky
and Knight to c6 is a non move in this
position but here we have d6 and it is
as of move 9 that we have a completely
new game so here TRUCKING contains
development we have Queen to c2
developing the Queen connecting rooks
Knight B to d7 black also wants to
continue development and now rook F to D
1 as the d6 pawn is a backwards pawn it
should be should be a target for the
rest of the game so trucky is getting
ready to pile up on the under d6 target
with Queen to e7 again
just developing the Queen connecting
rooks adding one of the defenders to the
pawn here and now Bishop to f4 and here
now this is a target and it's not easy
to defend this so you you kinda have to
either
well you want to push d5 at some point
in the game but it's it's it's never a
good moment for example even if you try
like Bishop captures and c3 to remove
one of the defenders just to the ship
captors and d6 is much faster you're
gonna lose I lose the rook and wife will
just win the game so here he five it
does prevent Bishop captures and v6 but
on the other hand you know you no longer
have a sixth to help you push d5 in the
future so this pawn is staying here
pretty much for the rest of the game
with Bishop to g5 now comes the ship
captain sea three Queen captures on c3
and now h6 attacking the bishop the
bishop doesn't have good good squares to
retreat so just the bishop characters
and f6 Knight captures on f6 and now
Knight to h4 offering a trade of light
square bishop and of course if black
declines the knight can even come to f5
which will be an excellent square and
this will add another attacker to the d6
pawn so here is LG G captures with
Bishop characters and Knight captures
and now rook F to b8 not allowing white
B for so grabbing more control of the be
for square we have night the e3 now the
knight can also come either either to d5
or to f5 word depends on where where
it's needed Queen the e6 and now comes
f3 just taking away the e4 n DG for
squares from the Black Knight we've
looked the b6 and now comes rook to d2
Chucky's prepares to double up rooks on
the on the D file to add more attackers
to the d6 pawn and of course this rook
is already nicely defending it well as
LG she wants to double up on the B file
and create some threats against the b2
pawn with g6 making a safer square for
the King and now rook a to d1 editing
another attacker to the d6 pawn rook a
to b8 now adding an attacker to the B to
point B 3 just getting that out of the
way and now King to h7 improving the
safety of the King King g2 Chucky does
the same and now look back to a 8 there
aren't any good breakthrough moves in
the future black should have some
breakthrough moves maybe we
for or h5h for maybe a five a four but
for the moment he goes rook to eight
probably with the idea of playing a five
a four choppy stops at with Queen to a5
and now h5 trying to create some other
ideas on the other side of the board as
the white queen is now all the way on
the Queen side we have h3 having a
flexible setup now okay if you pull the
point you can always put g4 it's not a
problem
King to g7 Kings to h2 with King back to
h7 here both of them are testing to see
what what the other guy is doing
Knight back to g2 and now Knight back to
g8 we have Knight back to III by truck
and not Knight back to e7 King to g2 and
the now came to g7 and here rook the d3
hard to say if rook to d3 is is actually
doing anything probably just another
slow maneuvering move but then again
it's chalky you know you know who knows
and like now like I said it might be
inviting efore so that's maybe that's
why why he did it
also h4 is an idea if h4 g4 is a very
very nice idea if he for this is very
very concrete that you would get Quintus
e3 check first f6 blocking check and now
F captures on e4 and then Queen captures
with check King to g1 so maybe this is
what Chuckie wanted to wanted on the
board for a fur game just to continue so
he doesn't have to repeat moves but as
LG goes for f5 instead which is a very
committal move as it it lowers the
safety of the black king but then again
you have much more support that when you
want to make a breakthrough with the
pawns so here Chucky finds a very
interesting idea he goes Knight to d5
and the Knights the d5 okay you you
should definitely capture it you do not
want it this knight on d5 also your rook
is under attack so you have to react
with Knight captures and rook captures
on d5 and here efore
now going for the breakthrough but here
Chucky has a very interesting tactic so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find Chucky's idea here while I give you
a couple of seconds
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on finding such a nice
tactic it's not an easy move to find and
for the zoo who just want to enjoy the
show it's rook captures on d6 yes it
does look a bit weird has d6 is guarded
twice but then again that's why the
knight was traded so you there's no
night any 720 c7 will come with check so
now if you capture it immediately Queen
to c7 check and you pick up the rook so
it's not a problem
first he captures a on f3 with check and
now okay if you capture with the pond
and you have 20 to check of course you
don't want to allow this after it
captures an f3 would check we have King
captures on f3 and now as L judge has to
decide what to do here whether to
capture right away or does you want to
go for Queen to e4 check Quinta e4 check
is very complicated but we will show it
as it's very interesting
for example queenie for check king
retreats king of two and now f4 just
going going going for it Queen back to
c3 bringing the Queen back into the
defense you don't have time for
something like rook captures here even
though it does seem like it's winning
material but F captors and g3 would
check is is enough for for blacks to
draw the game for example you cannot
capture if King captures Queen to e3
check and then you can bring the other
rook into the attack you will well
whatever you do you will be completely
lost here you can deliver check here the
King has to move once again if you go
here then even h4 is an idea you want to
open up lines and here what is just dead
lost but all in all it would be enough
for for him to draw the game so after f4
you will have to go for Queen to c3
check you have to bring the Queen back
into the defense and then now after the
King moves now for example if g4 then
you go rook after sandy six rook
captures and d6 and HK % g4 one of the
possible lines H captures and g4 in the
Queen to e7 now not allowing Queen to f6
and the now for example Queen h3 check
King g7 and now rook to d5 all in all
whatever black does White will always be
up that one pawn and in a better
position
since sharpie so conveniently grabbed it
with rookie actress and v6 but okay
after King captures an f3 as eltridge
doesn't doesn't enjoy Queen t4 right
away first he trades once rook captures
on d6 we have Queen to c7 check now the
point of our variation King to h8 and
now Queen captures and e6 Chucky offers
afraid of Queens which you cannot accept
if you trade captures captures then
you're white the white position is just
to easier already attacking g6 if you
defend it to just h4 you're going to go
King F or King g5 will grab this pawn
all of these pawns are falling so would
be completely winning for white so after
Queen captures and e6 now we have Queen
to e4 check result she doesn't want to
trade Queen's King f2 and look the eh
now going after the e2 pawn so Chucky
defends it and now comes Queen to e3
with check King to g2 and now King h7
the King will be much safer on h6 we
have Queen to f4 again offering a trade
here you could character for example
Queen captures G captures and go rook to
e3 it does prevent the White King from
getting activated for example if King
gift you're gonna pick up the pawn here
and even if look to h4 then if King
attacks the rook you can go rook to h3
and go after the point so this might
actually be a viable plan for black but
selcuk prefers to keep the Queen's on
the board with Queen to e7 and now King
f2 I'm just bringing the King closer so
the roof might also be activated the
King is now helping out with the defense
our but as long as Black has this Queen
rook battery along the e-file it's not
going to be that easy with a 5 by Zeltiq
and now
h4 by truck and here with a 4 yes this
breaks up the pawn structure on the
Queen side but it's not all that
problematic since Chuckie now gets a
passed pawn here we have looked a 8 now
he wants to collect gobble up all of
these pawns and now rook to d6 the idea
is okay you you're gonna worry about the
the past pawn here I'm gonna play for
example rook to c6 followed by rook to
c7 maybe I can win your queen we look
after Sunday for now comes
to see six threatening roof to see seven
and but now rook to e7
of course not allowing rook to see seven
and now a four Chuck is now free to put
the past a pawn since you can never
capture due to roof to c7 we have Queen
to d7 now attacking the rook here but
now rook captures on c5 only now do you
capture it you basically trade this
point for the past a pawn but you now
have a past C pawn so Queen captures on
a4 and now comes Luke the c7 check yes
now we've traded this point for this one
and the material is still Chucky's up
upon but the problem is now Chuck you
can trade rooks and well most of the
times when you have a queen and ponent
game it will also be that you should be
able to win it there will always be some
way but here it's just it's just much
easier here a black is in Czech King to
h6 and now again this is just a
beautiful position and a very
instructive one for because well you
will often find yourself in positions
where your queen against the Queen and
the pawn so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the best move for
white while I give you a couple of
seconds okay so for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations on
being an excellent centralizer of the
Queen and for those who just want to
enjoy the show it's well first let's see
if c5 which is of course you want to
push your passport it's already
protected here you la quinta d4 check
and then you allow a lot of checks
because here the Queen is just
controlling way too many squares and it
will be way too easy for you to harass
the white king there's just so many ways
you can do it
so not really something you want to do
if instead you found Queen to f7 which
guards the pawn and then maybe depending
on what black place maybe you can start
pushing it later also works but there is
a move that chalky played that is the
best it's Queen to e5 and it's just a
beautiful centralizing move point is
that if you now capture the pawn queen
to h8 is mate one of the reasons why
this pawn is so nicely placed on h4 so
you cannot of course accept the pawn
with King to h7 and only now thus
charkie pushed the past pawn with c5 we
have Queen to c6 blocking
the past pawn and now Queen e7 check
King to h6 and now Queen to d6 check
black cannot afford a clean trade
because the past pawn is simply too too
quick you can see that the black king is
way outside the square of the pawn so we
have Quinta h1 hoping to harass the
White King from behind but it will not
work
charkie pushes c6 Quinta H to check with
King to e3 and now Queen to g1 check
with King - D - so no more checks and
now Queen the b1 hoping to continue the
harassment but c7 we have Quinta a2 with
check King back to e3 now Quinta a7
check with King to d3 and Quinta a 8
guarding the queening Square but it's
not a problem we have Queen to c5 now
threatening just to promote the pawn to
Queen Quinta see it blocking and here
chuggy plate quick King today - and it
was in this position that a Robert
Zoellick resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here you could
just play something like Queen d6
threaten this but then you might allow
some checks a check he doesn't wanna
allow any checks so he just plays King
to d2 and the next
well you could go Queen d7 check King a1
I have to go back blocking but now you
just play Queen d6 next move you're
gonna bring the Queen here and it's a
game over whatever you play any move you
play you're just gonna go put the King
back King goes back doesn't really
matter where Queen d8 or for a queen
trade of course you cannot accept this
Queen to a6 you will still try to harass
the bow the White King a little bit but
after you bring the other Queen enter
game you will have very you you will
have a little luck doing it
King f2 and there are no more useful
okay Queen a7 chip
King g2 and now there are no more useful
checks and you can just resign here it'd
be interesting if you had maybe some
stale mating options but you don't you
have too many pawn moves and it's just
not possible if it was a completely
blockaded position okay you could play
something like this and try to get a
stalemate but unfortunately there are
too many pawn moves and white of course
is not forced to capture any Queens so
after King today to result you to
resigned and yet another excellent
victory for chalky and here we
you have the standing so let's just show
it Chuck you won the tournament with
seven and a half out of eleven followed
by BA search each ATM back road and
front mill cumin with seven out of 11
then with six eleven Marco soccer and
even cheaper enough then with five
Olivia theater Nyssa piano then with
four and a half Stanga coral and Robert
Zoellick
followed by Alexei DREV and then her OS
division modern poet
so very nice German for Chucky and by
not losing a single game seven and a
half out of eleven is a lot and he is
back in the twenty seven hundred club
which we mentioned in the previous video
but in case you missed it so that's that
concludes this tournament our little
short Sharky saga so I hope you enjoyed
it and you know we'll see where it goes
I would like to thank Peter Mitaka and
Terra Kulkarni for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and as always checking up on
everything that happens in the chess
world so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
Sunday or or if it's already Monday
where you're at hope you're enjoying
that as well